you know what else uh i started watching
was uh selling sunset
oh god i started watching selling sunset
and oh my god
of all the reality shows that is the
fakest yeah
i i can't believe how fake that is it's
about them selling real estate yes
and the two guys that run the company
the oppenheimer twins
will come into a room and say they come
into a room and say well ladies i know
we all
get along and you're you're all thick as
thieves and the best of friends i'm
we're introducing a new girl into the
equation
and they'll cut to one woman christine
or whatever and she'll be like
and they'll say i hope you all get along
i'd hate there for for there to be any
friction
they leave the room and they're all like
christine you better be nice when she's
like
well you know me i'm a [ __ ] that's
that's what i am so let's see this
new girl then christelle walks in
michelle
is that real yeah yeah yeah krishelle
her name was made of two other girls
names that crashed into each other
and they're like oh hi christelle and
she's like hi everybody
i come from very modest means but i hope
to do a good job cut to the mean one
look at those shoes who does she think
she is
and you're off to the races there's not
a real human moment in the whole thing
but you watch
all of it oh i i'm watching it and my
wife is saying oh my god i can't believe
christine got mad at cuschow and i'm
like what are you talking about yeah
so our marriage is over oh oh okay
yeah no i mean i can't if she's going to
be that easily duped
i can't be with her oh so it's over with
liza and now i'm dating
oh my god yeah we're keeping it on the
down low we're not telling a lot of
people
you know liza gets me in the divorce so
you always say that
yeah so i'm just my favorite line of
yours as you said
once lies is the only part of you i like
yep yep